Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my gosh, so I was going crazy listening to this song.
I feel like the BGM for this song is like 10 seconds long.
It has been repeating non-stop for the last 10 minutes.
I felt like I was going fucking crazy waiting for the stream to start.
But anyway, hello everyone!
I have some good news.
I fixed the problem with waking up at 6 30 a.m.
And you know what I did?
That couldn't wake me up at 6 30 in the morning anymore because I stayed up till 6 30.
I fixed it.
Modern problems needed modern solutions.
That's all I had to do.
If I stay up at 6 30 in the morning, woken up at 6 30 in the morning i did it what a brilliant plan i had um um but yes though i was playing rivals last night because like okay i have a little i have a sleep schedule problem right now because um right after stream yesterday i went and took a nap and i took a five to six hours quote unquote nap and i woke up at around 11 p.m and then i was like you know what i want to play Now that I'm awake,
I sort of want to play Rivals.
So I spent, like, I think I played Rink for, like, four to five hours.
And then I was like, you know what, now, you know what, I'm awake anyway.
I might as well just stay up a little longer.
Because, like, at that point, I ended the stream around, like, 5 a.m.
And so I was like, I'm not going to wait.
I'm not going to feed him an hour early because then he'll be, like, feeding time's going to be at 5 in the morning.
And so, so I was like, I might as well just stay up till 6.30, feed him, and then go to bed.
and and because I did that he didn't wake me up guys well he woke me up once but also guys it's crazy I also had it I also had another brilliant plan you know when I used to let him up on my bed for sleep time because it was like six 30 in the morning I closed my door I was like I literally was like pools closed so I closed my door so all I heard was the muffled sounds of him barking door but that's fine that's fine because it's a lot quieter it was such a revolutionary i i know it was so brilliant i don't know why i never thought about this before i just closed my door and that's all i had to do closing the door solved everything if i yeah exactly if i can't see the problem then it doesn't exist um champion metal thank you the super chat thank you thank you Stokey Bird.
Today is my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday from your majesty?
Of course, of course.
My humble dragons, my humble peasants in my kingdom.
Of course, I'll give you a happy birthday.
A happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear my subject, Champion Mel.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Uh, Oro, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Judges are morally exempt from being woken up to feed dogs or something.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, right after the stream, my manager woke up and got on his phone and texted me and was like, you do know that is a scam, right?
And then, I can't believe he would say that such a thing.
I am now legally a citizenship, a citizen of CELAD.
Not only am I a citizen, I am the Duchess of CELAD.
nation is a fucking scam.
I am so insulted.
I am royalty now.
Anyway, I was like, and then I ignored it.
I ghosted that question.
And then he was like, uh, you can, are you going to get a refund?
And then, you know, you know, being a me, I, of course, also didn't reply back.
I was like, oh yeah, you know how we have to have the sponsor?
Like, what are we supposed to do for that next week so anyway and I am I am very excited to play water park simulator I heard I heard a lot of good things about I heard a lot of good things about it people were having some people were getting really addicted to it it's basically like the TCG shop simulator where I mean it was pretty addicting i can tell why people really like playing it uh the tcg uh look i don't respond back to non-royals okay like look there's just there's just no connection you know like like talk to me when you have nobility in your blood uh
but anyway i heard that it was made really popular by keso and that's why everybody yeah peasant dare to speak to me i bet you have zero royal blood in you um um i i am a noble descent the highest by the way duchessness duchesses are the highest form of nobility below king queen so um i am of noble language okay um anyway uh queso actually what got got water park simulator number one in the twitch category by himself like he was like i think he was like rank one like water park simulator was rank one and it was single-handedly carried by queso because he had like 50 000 people watching him play water park simulator so i was like holy yeah um but that's really uh i saw i saw so many people playing it so I was like,
yeah, I'll give it a shot.
I mean, I enjoyed the TCG simulator, so I figured why not.
And I was looking through the settings, and I noticed something very interesting.
There is Twitch integration.
And I figured, why not?
Let's add some Twitch integration into this.
I don't know how to, I'm going to try to see if it can connect there.
So it's explanation point visit and explanation point.
hire me and as a new citizen of sea land I shall expand the micro nation and make new sea land in the middle of Canada just like Quebec I shall make new sea land and since this is own sovereign territory I the Duchess of sea land will take the responsibility of declaring a new minimum wage And if you get the honor of being hired here by me,
you can earn a huge whopping amount of $0.00 an hour because that's right, you get to work for royalty and that itself is already payment enough.
That's right.
What a deal.
Also, a ticket to New Zealand is $99.99, which is cheaper than Disneyland.
And I would say better than Disneyland.
No, better than Disney World.
All right, let's add Twitch integration real quick.
Give me a sec.
I don't know how, I wonder if that actually works.
All right, connect.
they connect it says connect please that is my twitch channel name oh wait i think it's they connect
i did a whole speech and everything okay why won't it connect i did an entire speech wait do i do live on twitch to have twitch integration oh okay well that's awkward I love that that's that's a little okay guys let's just pretend you're I thought I could just connect you about it as long as the chat's working I thought I thought I could just borrow my twitch chat for my youtube stream all right sorry guys pools closed apparently I can't connected Apparently guys,
I'm sorry pool is closed.
Anyway, new game Don't worry I'll open I'm opening New Zealand to to the journalists and the social like and and the and the Influencers so you guys can get like it's like the Universal Park place the what was that the you know The new Universal Park where they opened it to only influencers to record everything.
That's That's right.
New Zealand.
Create.
Sorry, it's closed beta right now.
This is closed beta New Zealand.
You quit your hated job and used your last savings to chase a dream.
You bought an old abandoned water park.
Can you restore it to its former glory or will it fail just like it did under its previous owner?
Hey Joe, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I thought Quebec in the middle of the hand that was already called Alberta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh shit, Twitch chat on the screen?
I didn't even notice.
I forgot to take it off from before.
Alright, my new sea land.
As the Duchess of sea land, I shall expand the propaganda of sea land and establish new sea land in the middle of Canada.
So they shall know our name.
We deserve to be recognized by other countries.
We are the micro-names.
that deserves recognition.
This dusty broken down Wi-Fi has definitely seen some better days.
But you're here to change all that.
First, let's cure all the old buildings.
Use your sledgehouse.
Okay, what old building am I clearing, though?
This way?
I don't understand.
What?
Oh, here?
But this is a cool pool.
Look at this.
I can fix this pool up.
I just gotta get rid of the trash and clean it up.
exactly five-star cleaning this hell trash is everywhere and let's be real no one's lining up to relax next to a pallet of old soda cans grab a trash bag and clean up the best and toss it all by holding it into the trash bag okay i'll destroy this trash oh wait where's the trash bin where is it oh it's over here i think this is already bigger than the original sea land
bigger than the oil rake in the middle of the ocean.
All right, let's grab this.
All right, we're crashed.
Oh, I need more trash bags.
I already had some.
Oh, no, I didn't.
Oh, I accidentally threw, like, empty trash in the trash bag.
That's right.
What would Sea Lime do without me, guys?
Look at me go.
I'm already...
expanding our land.
Oh.
Here you go.
Chuck chuck.
Oh wait, I can just, I can just, like, Kobe it.
Alright, let's grab all of this trash away.
Here I'll go.
It's so hard being a sovereign in two different countries.
For Doki London, New Zealand.
what a oh my gosh what a difficult time for dokeybird what a such a tough life being nobility in two different esteemed countries so rough i'm so brave yeah so so brave of me oh wait was i wasting money oh i didn't realize i thought trash bags are free as i could just grab it off the streets building your park can't have a water park without a pool each pool you build raises the number of mass guests your max guests your park can have press b uh to open the menu immigration feed in new zealand law live duchess joki yabe yabe thank you for the super chat thank you thank you okay but you still gotta pass the immigration test you can't just be a citizen new zealand just like that we have like we have like a hundred like a hundred questions for you to answer to pass the citizen test question one is are you subscribed to dokeybird question two are you following dokeybird on twitch question three are you following dokeybird on twitter question four have you bought dokeybird merch dokeybird
.com question five do you follow her on tick tock yeah that's so far so good all right question six are you a member of dokeybird on youtube.com what will i do press b oh i have to build i build my goddamn pool let's just put it like right here i think this is the perfect place you know you get down the stairs and you could just you can oh my it's so safe in new zealand like you know the the stairs is the diving pool the board oh my god that's ocean regulated right there you go here and be like yay and then pray you don't hit your legs but that's okay that's the fun of it the risk is the fun
breaking their legs is the least of their worries it's the neck that they gotta figure out if they can it'll be okay all right build I passed everything but ticked out.
I'm sorry your application got declined.
I don't know we cannot provide you the information why your application was declined.
By the way, every time you some when you submit an immigration assistant an immigration form to become a citizen of New Zealand, it is a $50 fee per application.
So and that's the low end by the way.
If you get the immigration premium form, it's actually with a low, low price of $99.99.
And by getting the immigration premium form, you'd only have to do 10 questions instead of 100.
It's like our little fast pass.
I'm the water plug and the closer to fill the...
Okay, oh, there's the water plug.
Thank you for the red.
Thank you.
What a deal.
That's like our little fast pass.
Also.
Press beat up.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I have a diving board.
Why do I need a diving board when I have the stairs right there?
Why do I need that?
I literally have the stairs for that.
Also, New Zealand, we only accept euros.
We're not a European Union, but we only accept euros as a currency in New Zealand.
We're not a European Union, but we still only accept euros.
even put any magenta soup but thank you thank you i wanted or bitcoin of coin we'll we'll do bitcoin too all right our national currency is euros and bitcoin all right build oh i didn't build it yet here's our here's our cryptocurrency wallet if you wish to submit your application
time to open preparations are done go to the go to the ticket office and open the park with a button on the wall once you're open for business start selling those tickets choose the right time age and pass type print it out and pass it to your eager guests let them come all right all right i'm so sad i can't have my free staff but work for exposure I'm so sad I gotta open it oh it's right here it's like where's the button it just says staff only all
right all right come one come on what's this add time oh press for what about six hours I give you money?
How do I get?
Oh, it's because you're a teen.
Oh, I have to get it exact.
Wait, how do I I don't give it to you?
Oh!
Oh, there it is.
What about six hours?
Come on.
Unbelievable?
Well, you're still here.
Oh, no!
Wait, did she buy it?
She paid for it already, right?
$5.
Okay.
Did she pay for it?
I couldn't tell.
Oh, it was just a suggestion.
She didn't have to.
She didn't have to take the ticket.
She was a teenager anyway.
She would have peed in the pool.
Eight hours.
What the fuck are you doing in my pool for eight hours?
I should just ban you for life after that.
Like.
You can spot them quite easy to push them out to send a message.
No ticket.
Who came in?
Who came into my park?
Who was it?
Okay, I gave you... Was it you?
Get out of here!
That's right!
No free... Where's your citizenship for C-Lan?
You didn't pay the...
You didn't pay the $50.
That's what you're gonna... Get out!
That's right!
Leave!
Get out of here that's oh i'm so sorry sir i'm so sorry i'm so sorry sir to make it up for you here is a free uh complimentary coupon to have to get what to have a drink of water at our fountain that's right slip on that that's a thing oh shit oh shit it's okay i'm okay i'm all right Get the mob from the tool shed.
Who would have thought there's water in my water park?
Alright, here we go.
Lost the tool?
If you drop the man in two shed, always he's...
Oh, okay.
And so I can just chuck it whenever.
Pre-coup.
Ah!
Where is this water made of?
This is not H2O.
Someone's slimy up my pool.
Moppy, moppy Moppy, moppy Why is the water wet?
Swing slides are real stars of the water Not everyone's a thrill seeker Make sure to check if guests want a slide pass When selling a ticket Offer then they'll turn around and leave No, don't leave This is a fun pool What do I do for flyers Oh Oh, not enough inventory space?
How do I drop?
Hi, would you like to come to my pool?
Have you guys heard of New Zealand?
Hello, have you heard of New Zealand?
It's a great place.
Oh my god, my first paying customer.
Alright.
Let's see.
What does she want?
Four hours.
A dog.
Oh my god, I'm making so much money for New Zealand.
Hello, sir.
Would you...
Oh, wait, there's some potential customers right there.
Sir, ma'am, would you like to be a citizen of New Zealand?
Hello, sir.
Would you also like to be a citizen?
Oh, that's... You're not going to the...
Hello, you're not... Oh, wait, wait, are you going?
Is he going?
Oh, he is.
She wasn't, though.
Ma'am!
Ma'am, have you heard of New Zealand?
Wait, where did she go?
Wait, ma'am.
Ma'am!
I was just trying to spread the...
I always want to tell her about the great history of Sealand.
Alright, eight hours.
You're a teenager?
Holy shit.
You drank so much milk.
Alright, let's print some flies.
I gotta spread the propaganda of Sealand.
Where is it?
Sir!
Would you like to be a Sealand?
of New Zealand.
We offer a lot of cool things like a water park.
Oh, look at that!
Guys, we're expanding our GDP.
Our gross domestic product.
Archie, my boy.
Alright.
We're ours, senior.
Here you go, sir.
I hope you enjoy New Zealand.
my kingdom continues to grow man have you heard of new zealand we have a lot of wildlife and tours that you can participate yay
look at that um my windows are not nasty this is a historical site this the the The dirt and grime on my window originated all the way from 1800s when Celand was first liberated from the British.
Okay, six hours.
This is a historical site.
How dare you ask me to clean my windows?
It is vintage.
Oh, I should.
Where's my mom?
Oh, yeah.
I need to use my flyer.
I need to recruit another citizen.
Sir, sir!
Would you like to be a citizen of New Zealand?
It's only $50 for the application form.
Because I like your face, I'll give you a trial period, too.
Yay!
See, guys, it works.
See, guys?
Everyone loves sea land.
Okay, let's clean up.
Let's clean this up.
Yay!
I'm a marketing genius.
They should make me the chief financial officer of C-Lan.
Oh my god.
The stupid...
Why am I not wearing sandals?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I have to be live on Twitch to have free staff.
uh six hours senior don't worry sir i got you
four hours teenager don't worry here you go all right i gotta build what was this live that's what they want in new zealand here we go if you wait a sec the fun of it is whether or not you actually hit the That's what that's the fun of it See this rocks everybody loves New Zealand
He said it rocks Oh my god Prince Prince Michael is gonna love this from chill to relief Running around the water pack is fun, but even the most need a break sub comfy loungers for relaxation make sure toilets are nearby All right guys do not pee on the pool I swear to God.
Alright, we'll put that.
We'll put it all the way back here.
There you go.
That's far...
What a great view.
You get to look at the nature of New Zealand.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, my favorite water park owner.
I just want to ask if New Zealand is up to OSHA standards.
It is 100% up to OSHA.
standards in fact we at New Zealand have our own OSHA workers because we are a sovereign micro nation so we we have our own set of OSHA laws that I've personally I oh my god someone pooped you can do that what do I do what do I do do I just grab it oh my god um what do I do what do you do Why is your poop in my...
Oh my god, why is your poop in my...
Who was it?
Who pooped in the pool?
Who is this freak in New Zealand?
I will deport you.
Wait, what is that?
Is that a piece of trash, too?
That's it.
Someone's getting deported here.
I...
Oh, fuck.
Why did it get up?
Oh, wait, I should actually build a pool.
How do I...
I should really build a bathroom.
Where the fuck are the bathrooms?
I have decorations.
Where is the bathroom?
Have I not yet unlocked the bathroom?
Society, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mudge, thank you for the super chat.
I shouldn't be eating while watching.
wait is it right by the slide there's no bathroom what the fuck is my bathroom I built a lounger right here I have two lounges how much many more lounges do they want I'll put it like here there you go it's beautiful wait there was a yeah oh shit i oops all right front row seat to the nature to the to the nature of new celand okay now i can build a toilet all right right here just so it's convenient right here oh my god you fucking can i am building the fucking it right now,
guys.
Please, relax.
I already did the flyer thing.
I did it early.
Because I needed more subjects in my kingdom.
Alright, let's scoop the poop.
Poop, scoop.
Alright, let's get the trash out.
Where are they putting all this trash from?
I do not have a lot of... Guys, please do not raise the pH levels of my pool, guys.
I...
guys please please do not raise the ph levels of my pool it's very expensive to upkeep hello ma'am would you like to be a citizen of new zealand it's only 50 hey the pool is hello new zealand is that way guys hello noelle oh she already wants a ticket okay hello would you like to be a citizen of new zealand um the pool is to your right ma'am um Ma'am,
that's not where the pool...
That's not where the pool is!
Alright, okay, here.
Ma'am, would you like to be a citizen of New Zealand?
Hello, ma'am.
That's also not where the pool is.
Please turn back.
Don't worry.
I know it must be very hard.
I can push you back.
Don't worry.
I can push you back to the pool.
It's the other side.
Come on.
You know you want to go there.
Oh, hey, daily report.
72 to 10.
Oh, nine guests.
I have a 40% satisfaction.
This is the Sea Land welcome.
The art of the idea.
Sea Land is launching an attack.
New Sea Land will not rest.
I have a 10 out.
Yeah.
Alright.
I should maybe clean up a little bit.
Just a little bit.
I can't be the way.
I'm going to try this again oh i should save game settings come on connect come on you know you want to how to i need my i need my staff staff work how to connect water park simulator to twitch twitch integration not working enter hit connect and a bot name oh okay you can go into the enter hit connect and a bot name water park simulator mirrors wait okay wait is he there is that bot there is he in my is he in my chat water water oh my god he's not they lied to me they first step be live on twitch
I can't believe it.
How do I get this to work?
I don't understand.
I did every step.
What else could I be missing?
I don't understand.
What else could I be missing from this integration?
no deal streaming is too much work I should have to set up everything oh shit all right let's just clean this up it truly is such a mystery guys what a big mystery we'll never know how to fix it not actually clean my slide no it's just gonna be like that just hope you don't get tinnitus not tinnitus what is that thing where uh tinnitus is for when you're in war uh just no tetanus shot just make sure you get your tetanus shots guys like before you visit new zealand you just gotta make sure You get your tetanus shots.
It's just, it's like vaccines, you know?
You know how, like, if you want to go to this country, you got to get some vaccinations.
Like, if you want to visit New Zealand, just make sure you have a tetanus shot.
Like, it's just, you know, just basic country things.
Basic culture stuff you got to follow.
You know?
It's got to make sure.
It's just a simple request.
I mean, if you don't get it, you're legally not allowed to sue us.
Because we warned you.
Basic country things.
Like, you don't get your tennis shots before you visit a new country?
Someone's not prepared.
I guess that makes sense.
Right up, Flyers.
Oh, wait, but I already did do that.
How did all these puddles come to be?
I don't under...
Where are all this water coming from?
Actual too much water.
Also, I hope the sound's been okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Also, the great thing about New Zealand is that you don't need to get a visa to visit here.
You need a visa to...
I mean, you might need a passport to come into Canada.
But after that, it's so easy to get into New Zealand.
Just gotta get a passport to get into Canada.
Because we're sort of like in the middle of But that's okay.
All right.
Oh no, my hammer.
Oh, I got flyers.
Hello.
Ma'am, would you like to be a citizen of New Zealand?
Oh, nice.
See, it's just that easy.
Look at that.
I'm already upping.
I'm already increasing the population of New Zealand.
Okay, I know you didn't pay.
All right.
Slide pass.
What are you doing?
Are you a teen?
Yes.
Four hours.
Give me a sec.
Get out of here!
Oh, we're deporting your ass!
Get deported!
Alright.
Slide past adult eight hours.
Nice.
That's right.
I'm also the immigration officer, too.
I think I won't deport your ass.
Okay.
Yeah, we might not Wait, oh We might not have visas, but Oh, I maxed and gave her A slide pass I gave her an Extra benefit and she got Mad?
Like, what kind of Privileged bitch are you?
Like, I gave her a Bonus and she got mad at me
I like, I basically gave her immigration premium and she didn't want it.
Alright, time to print out some more flowers.
Can I just keep printing flowers?
How much is flowers?
Oh, it's $5.
$5 for three pieces of paper?
Where am I getting this printed off?
Some fucking some fucking indie hipster who owns like the paper is made of organic material?
Why is it $5?
Hello, would you like to be a citizen of New Zealand?
Nice.
Your progress feels discovery.
Gain next to me from every action you take.
And once you get enough, you'll earn a research point.
Head over to the research table.
Guest gets hungry.
Oh, I'm a new citizen of New Zealand.
All right.
Slide past teen six hours.
There you go.
Here's your ticket, ma'am.
Here's your visa.
I'm like...
I'm immigration.
I'm doing papers, please, right now.
Slide past four hours, team.
Here you go.
Papers, please.
Hello, Edison.
So why are you visiting the great country of New Zealand?
Four hours, team.
Slide past.
Of course, here you go.
Here's your stamp.
Oh, yeah, I saw her.
I saw that bitch.
Don't worry.
I'm going to deport her.
Don't worry, guys.
She ain't welcome in New Zealand.
I'm going to take a photo of her and put her in there.
around behind my behind my board so everyone will know i'll shame her in front of all of new zealand all right get over here i see you i'm going right in the water get you that's right get out of here get deported oh no she's not drowning guys if she dies in new zealand legally um they can't do anything about it because uh the new zealand police said there was no foul play Oh,
I can go to the research tab.
How do I go to the research tab?
How do I go?
Well, if the New Zealand police said there was no foul play, then what can I do?
You know?
My hands are tied.
Oh, it's in the tool shed.
Oh, there it is.
Hot dog stand.
Hot dog.
Nice.
Can I be the hot dog stand now?
Oh, I can.
Alright, I'll put it next to the bathroom.
So it'll be like...
So, oh wait, I can't.
I'll put it next to the bathroom.
So if they, you know, after a good...
After a good meal, they can just, you know, use the bathroom right after.
It's so convenient.
The most convenient water park.
There we go.
Uh-oh, your son's at a hot dog.
No one comes to a water park with just the water.
Alright, that's fine.
I'll grab some hot dog.
in my neighboring country, the great Kmart.
Oh wait, let me, all right, hi ma'am, ma'am.
Would you like to become a citizen of New Zealand?
Ma'am, would you also like to become a new citizen of New Zealand?
Sir, sir, would you like to be a, excuse me, New Zealand is not foreign.
I am doing great reform, financial reform for this country.
Okay, nice, let me grab some hot dogs.
Goodbye.
Okay, we're gonna restock the hot dogs real quick.
Not all guests.
Every now and then special guests might show up.
Some loud, some funny, some just plain.
How dare you slander a great nation of New Zealand?
Go to a slave.
That's right.
Did you hear that?
If you're too smelly, you get deported.
Teeing for eight hours.
Bad!
Okay.
All right.
Excuse me.
So what the fuck case though case though just because you have a your multi-million doesn't mean you could do this in the great country of New Zealand Wait, he ate all my hot dog
Okay, do I Okay He has diplomatic just cuz just cuz you're multi-millionaire doesn't mean you have diplomatic immunity in a great nation in New Zealand All right guys, I have a moral dilemma Do I buy hot dogs or do I save someone from drowning?
I...
Guys, I have a moral dilemma right now.
I can make it back.
I think I can make it back.
It's fine.
I think so.
They can't...
Like, I can just perform CPR.
It'll be fine.
Hot dogs bring more joy.
Exactly.
All right.
Here you go.
Don't worry.
I got you Wait, oh shit, it's that the oh my god, where is it where is it?
Oh fuck.
Oh, where is that?
Oh my god, it's over here Don't worry.
Don't worry.
I got you
Guys, I think she's okay.
I got you.
Oh my god, where's my hot dog?
Wait, is she okay?
I think she's fine.
No, I think everything will be fine.
Oh, my med kit.
I got you.
Oh my god, I forgot.
Oh my god, please.
Give me a sec.
Where's my other med kit?
There you go.
See, she's okay.
See, I owe you one.
Look at that.
I saved a life today, guys.
All right.
this.
I'm a hero.
I saved our life.
All right, nice.
Hello, I shall deport you.
God, it's a death.
No, no, no.
I saved lives today, guys.
I'm a hero.
Get rid of this trash.
Here this I am a hero right now all right mustard ketchup I think there's more trash in the pool what the fuck how did that sink where are they getting the water bottles from I said no outside food and drinks you have to purchase everything on in New Zealand.
Alright, here you go.
Look, you gotta help the Sea Land economy if you wish to be a citizen here.
You can't just outsource it to a different.
We're gonna add tariffs.
If you bring outside food and drink, I will tariff it.
That's not the tariff.
this is contraband in new zealand think of the think of my economy
how dare you bring outside food and drinks in the great in the great nation of new zealand after all i did for all of you i let you in my country and you dare break food and drinks?
After everything I did.
I gave you the honor of paying $50 for an immigrant into my great nation.
My great micro nation.
How ungrateful.
She's going off the defense.
Oh wait I need two more.
Guys.
My lovely subjects.
Please buy a hot dog.
Come on.
Oh, come on.
You know you want a hot dog.
Come on.
No, no, no.
You get a hot dog.
Oh, she just wants the poop.
Where are all my hot dog enjoyers?
Maybe if I print some more flyers.
Oh, wait.
I gotta throw it.
My broom.
I need more like hands or some shit.
Why do I have five or inventory slots?
I have so many pockets She just how dare you this is how this is slander.
I'll have you trial in my court
All right six hours slide pass.
Oh, there you go get him
Yeah a dog.
Oh, you want a slide pass, too.
Oh, no.
Here's the slide pass.
Put the flyers down.
Maybe someone would want to... Does anyone want to buy a hot dog?
Hot dogs, yeah.
Get your hot dogs.
Some really delicious hot dogs.
See?
He knows what's up.
I said it was really delicious.
And He knows what's up.
Sonic, thank you.
In the super chat, thank you.
Here comes a new...
Okay, but defunct land is based off of amusement parks.
This is the sovereign micro-nation of New Zealand.
This is different.
Hot dogs.
Get your hot dogs.
Made from premium.
What are hot dogs made of?
Made from premium cows, pigs, and other sorts of animals.
Hot dogs, get your hot dogs.
In New Zealand, the meat might surprise you.
Oh my god, it's that late.
Maybe I should not build my slide at the edge of that pool.
Nah, it's the risk.
The fun of it is the risk that you might break your neck.
It's a good souvenir from New Zealand.
It's a good story to tell to your family and friends, you know?
Like, oh man, you want to know how I got these cars?
I just need to sell one more hot dog.
It's like a gambling, exactly.
It's a gambling water park.
with the lawsuits um there's no lawsuits in New Zealand because we have our own sets of laws and you willingly by buying a ticket to New Zealand you willingly decided to agree to the terms of conditions of my nation we do not follow Canadian law we are our own nation in the middle of Canada self-governing party and i am one of and i am the self-governing party
that's right all right i'll go see i still need to sell one more hot dog we do not answer to the u.s until the u.n acknowledges sealand as a sovereign state we do not law governed by the UN we only follow the laws of other nations who acknowledges C-Land as a as a sovereign state that's right if you don't acknowledge if they don't acknowledge us as a real country then why should I follow your rules Like,
glory to sea land.
Glory to all.
Long live sea land.
Glory to the motherland.
So true.
I'm sorry.
If they don't acknowledge me, I don't acknowledge them.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Remember to like this stream that you have ad block on PC that YouTube excludes you in the CCB.
It's the sick thing in the super chat.
Thank you.
And I worked at the most visited waterfront in the world.
And it was just like this.
Yep.
See, I'm doing everything right.
Alright.
Sea Land is now open.
Papers, please.
Also, I saw a sound guy said.
Increase the sound effects.
Okay, sound effects are already 100%.
That's fine.
Exactly.
Why is scrub if it's going to get wet again?
That's what I'm saying.
It's the water part.
The Geneva Convention?
More like Geneva Suggestion.
Let's see.
Four hours.
Slide pass.
Slide pass team.
Here we go.
Welcome to New Zealand.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
Alright.
Oh shit, more customers.
Uh, six hours senior.
Wait, did you want to slide past?
No slide past.
Welcome to New Zealand.
Enjoy your stay.
Hello, Ryland.
Uh, eight hours.
Slide past senior.
Welcome to New Zealand.
Enjoy your stay.
Wait, what?
Oh shit.
Wait, what did he... I thought...
Oh, he wanted...
eight hours.
Oops, sorry.
I didn't even want you.
I didn't want you in my country anyway.
You don't want to be a citizen.
I don't even want you as a citizen.
I bet you don't even pay for my taxes.
Oops.
Let me hit.
That's the round ticket.
What?
What ticket did I get wrong?
I'm sorry.
English is so hard.
We don't speak English in New Zealand.
I have to learn an entire new language to run this country.
I'd like to be a citizen.
Oh, he wanted a slime.
Fast.
Teen.
Six hours.
I speak sea landlish.
Okay, nice.
I literally just need one hot dog.
All right, flowers time.
All right.
Hello, sir.
Oh, Yuri wants a ticket.
Hello, ma'am.
Have you heard of the new sovereign micro-nation called New Sealand?
We are expanding the Sealand territory.
We are tired of being in the middle of ocean, so now we're landlocked.
Me!
I have to...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
That's fine.
The dragoons already went forth.
All right.
item.
That should be correct.
Hello.
Welcome to New Zealand.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
6 hours.
Teen, adult.
Welcome to New Zealand.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
Please remember the...
Oh my god, Jerry.
I see you, Jerry!
Just because you're in a different game, I'll always know you're there.
That's right, Jerry.
Come on, I'm waiting for you.
That's right.
He'll never...
Jerry will never expect this.
I see you You can escape me, Jerry Oh, wait, he That's right Get deported I was like Wait a minute, where did he go?
Oh, you wanted a slide pass Wait, he did Christian Uh, four hours Slide pass Adult, there you go Hello Welcome New Zealand.
Enjoy your stay.
Make sure to get the complimentary water.
8 hours.
Slide past senior.
Welcome New Zealand.
Hope you enjoy your stay.
6 hours.
Slide past teen.
Welcome to New Zealand.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
We have a lot of great wonderful melodies around New Zealand.
Make sure to try out our New Zealand hot dogs.
The meat might surprise you.
It's our national dish.
Would anyone like some hot dogs?
Hot dogs!
Get your New Zealand hot dogs!
It's shaped like New Zealand!
Hello?
Anyone want some hot dogs?
Oh, is this what she's the Duchess of?
Me!
Hello, sir.
Excuse me.
How dare you!
you know that we have a prince and his name is Michael wait out of order how is our pool out of order how do I repair oh I just hammer it guys don't you guys if the pool is 20% water please do not jump in the pool I how is that my fault that she got injured does she not have you have eyes Stacy you please do not jump you have eyes you can't just say that I broke Oshala when you jumped in the pool with 20% water how did I get fine for her stupidity she literally just won the Darwin a Darwin award all right nice I I should have needed that.
Let's see.
I know.
I hope you enjoy the national dish of Ceylon.
Yay!
All right.
Sell ticket.
Build one trash bin.
Oh, I should be able to build that.
Wait, do I have to research that?
Water gun.
Looks like one guest has gotten cold feet.
Approach the guest and sometimes they can take a punch.
All right.
Don't worry.
I can help you.
You just need a little encouragement.
There we go.
See?
Everything is fine.
Just a little encouraging knock, you know?
Knock, knock.
Oh, rusty pool fillers.
I gotta clean this.
Let's just click on it.
Oh, there we go.
All clean.
So take it Build a trash can and a shower.
How do I build that?
Maintenance.
Basic toilets.
Bigger.
Oh, there you go.
Rusty showers.
Nice.
And trash bins.
That's what we needed.
All right.
We'll put the trash bin next to the hot dogs, then.
Oh, shit.
He wants hot dogs.
Here you go.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
What would you like?
um hello i'm oh my god hello excuse me i my hot dog is right sir please do not hold the line get in there all right oh my god what happened to you did you get a heat stroke don't worry clear
hello great would you still like your hot dog ketchup all right hope you enjoyed your nap of cringe look he paid me ten dollars because i was a hero today for hours slide passing welcome to new zealand i hope you enjoy your stay out of order again who sold me this fucking faulty part
please don't give me a fine there we go uh oh i don't have any more hot dogs i gotta go I gotta buy it from my neighboring.
It's imported hot dogs.
I gotta buy this hot dog.
I know.
Don't worry.
I got it here.
We made it all in New Zealand.
This is our national cuisine.
All made in the country of New Zealand.
Not imported anywhere else.
I'll fix this out of order.
this is a domestic product um the the hot dogs here are a domestic product of new zealand how dare you imply otherwise all right we'll put up shower next to the toilet so like we don't waste the water all right here you go this is so smart by having this next to the toilet if you instead Like,
um, people can use this as a second toilet, you know?
They can pee in the shower.
My feet, then sit down if your feet hurt.
I have to build two showers?
Okay, I got this.
Uh, we'll put another shower right here.
There you go.
Oh, don't worry, guys.
Clean yourself with the water.
From the water with water.
on both there you go hope you enjoy your hot dogs hot dogs hello, hello, ma'am 6 hours team welcome to New Zealand I hope New Zealand hope you enjoy your stay please don't confuse us with New Zealand we are a landlocked country oh shit it's fine he already left he already left the country yay yay See,
you could do that.
Why use a jump board when you can just jump from the stairs?
We are the superior country.
It's a common mistake.
Um.
Here you go.
Hope you enjoy our domestic national dish.
Oh.
Hello, ma'am.
Four hours.
Slide past senior.
Welcome to New Zealand.
Hope you enjoy your stay.
a wonderful beautiful country oh no there's too much trash that's okay Kobe
I should start picking I'm selling the trash here when can I when can I hire workers
whoo oh wait I almost hit that slam dunk 360 no scope Wait, I still miss I have so many citizens Why can't they start working for me?
Mop, mop Will I get fine?
I just leave all these puddles around I can just be like I could just say this is like One of the wonderful traits of New Zealand All the natural Water
See when you enter when you enter new zealand you automatically become a citizen and you're legally required to pay the taxes as was decreed you
get your id card and now you're congratulations you are a citizen of new zealand wait what oh daily report i was gonna be like what happened
I can't oh wait it went down less people got hurt this time that's called kidnapping all right let's see I'm injured I can't find a trash bin I need okay loungers and trash bin all right it seems to fix our bad reviews we just need more chairs and trash bins and nothing else and everything else is okay that's fine that's something I can handle let's fix this chair it's the little things yeah that's the only two critiques that I could see I just didn't have enough chairs didn't have enough chairs and and trash bins just small things all right mop mop see I'll go fix this all right I fixed the toilet look they're not crusty it's vintage guys I give a vintage experience I'll repair this chair can't give my guests some splinters that's what the pool is for
all right I'll fix this
nice is there anything else to fix all right mop mop mop mop mop mop that's not black mold guys it's just paint that I spilled okay I need what trash bin I guess I could put another try I give my trash bin in the pool but here and then more lounges so people can see our beautiful nature there There you go.
Front row seat.
The beautiful nature that New Zealand provides.
Alright.
Everything is going up for us.
As the chief financial officer, and CEO, and HR, and also social media, and special promotion, I think we're doing a pretty good job.
all right new ceiling is open
welcome new citizens oh no space of inventory do i have to clean i have to clean my chairs oh my god wait i i didn't realize that's a thing i thought it was just a natural color um it's vintage guys i'm just making my chair vintage
what is the seat Placement.
And so they can see the beautiful nature of New Zealand.
Look at this luxurious green and tree and forestry that surrounds our beautiful country.
Wee!
Look at that.
So safe.
Hello, ma'am.
Deported.
You gotta pay a price if you wish to be a citizen here.
I hope you enjoy.
Welcome to New Zealand.
I should...
Alright, let's grab this and this.
And throw it out.
Kobe!
Nice, though!
Oh yeah.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to spread the glory propaganda in New Zealand.
Would you like to go?
to new zealand we have fresh water all localized in our country would you also like to come to excuse me you were here yesterday are you trying to tell me that we did not give you the the satisfaction that you required well maybe you might have never existed
can't be unsatisfied if you were you were never here in the first place yay So many wonderful citizens that want to come to New Zealand.
So many people that heard great things about our wonderful nation.
Welcome to New Zealand.
Please enjoy our complimentary water.
We have never received a negative review once.
And if we have, it's a shame that they died next day.
Quite a shame.
Hello, Mari.
Six hours, live past a duck.
Welcome to New Zealand.
Please enjoy a complimentary water.
Six hours, a duck.
Alright, Sarah, give me a sec.
I gotta help.
I gotta help this guy.
Face your fear.
Face your fear!
Alright, nice.
Oh, wait, he fucking...
Wait, he wasn't even a pain.
customer.
Excuse me, I shall deport you now.
Wait, I helped him.
I helped him face his fears, but yet he's illegally in my country.
Alright.
Four hours, teen.
Hope you enjoy your stay in New Zealand.
Four hours, adult.
Please enjoy your stay in the wonderful sovereign micro state of New Zealand.
New Zealand.
I should buy more hot dogs.
My wonderful neighboring country.
Kmart.
This is my only import.
The hot dogs.
See, everybody loves our country.
Look at that.
I can't believe they won't recognize us.
I don't understand.
Nice, oh, I guess it wants a, wants a ticket.
Oh, you think I didn't catch you?
Get out of here.
Yeah, go back to K-Mark where you belong.
All right.
Let's see.
But I want, oh yeah, I gotta fix my slide.
Oh, my slide is okay.
Slide pass, senior, six hours.
here in the wonderful new sovereign state.
I know.
There's a lot of good things around here.
We offer a lot of amenities for young and old citizens.
Hey, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome to Doki Lawn, where access may or may not happen.
People never disappear.
And what do you mean, war crime, Mr. Ambassador?
Money for you, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Exactly.
Nothing ever bad happens in Doki Lawn.
and the wonderful new sovereign state of New Zealand.
Whoa!
See?
Look how safe this place is.
Sir, you are holding up the land.
But don't worry, a little encouragement does not hurt.
All right, we need like three more.
Hello!
New Zealand, come!
Excuse you!
You never existed.
Hello, New Zealand, come!
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Sir, would you like to come to New Zealand?
Yay!
See?
Coming to our beautiful country brings so much joy.
It can cure anything.
Even broken bones.
What a miracle place.
What a wonderful place.
Good marketing right there.
You come to New Zealand, you'll be cured of all ailments.
I'm like repairing my I'm repairing this body oh wait is that one okay marketing in forest hammer oh shit stop that's stop standing in front of the broken boy
wait you're not even yeah I'm I was going to say, you're not even a paying customer.
Eight hours.
Papers, please.
Here's your paper.
All right, last guess I have to sell to.
What is he what?
Six hours.
Senior.
No slide.
Here you go.
Guess where you're too long for a hot dog?
Don't worry.
Yay!
I got one Look at that.
We have a thriving economy.
Basic.
You cannot park without these.
What?
Essential hydration.
Uh, bigger pockets.
Okay, we need bigger pockets.
I'm so done with.
I already have bigger pockets.
Wait, how many research points do I?
Oh, I have more.
I have so many research points.
I'll grab a lemonade stand.
And then...
I'll grab a water gun.
And I guess I could do a...
I'll grab all of these.
Okay.
Let us pick up this trash.
Where are the worker slots?
Oh shit.
They were like this when I got here!
They didn't sign...
It's not my fault.
They signed a consent form.
Legally, if they die in sea land, Their bodies just mysteriously disappear.
It's crazy.
It's crazy, guys.
So many people mysteriously disappeared in New Zealand.
Alright.
I'll clean up.
Mop, mop, mop, mop.
Alright.
We're doing so well.
What the fuck?
How do we have so many people?
They got in here.
How did y'all got in here?
That's like, leave!
We don't want you here!
No free lawyers in New Zealand, only paying citizens.
We gotta raise our GDP.
Alright.
Slide pass.
Enjoy your stay.
John Madden.
Slide pass.
Enjoy your stay in New Zealand.
Anything else I gotta clean?
Oh shit.
I thought the pool was supposed to be this color.
Oops.
You mean my pool wasn't my pool isn't supposed to be brown?
Who would have thought?
How was I supposed to know my pool?
Was it supposed to be Brad?
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I got you, sir.
As a lifeguard of this facility.
I got you.
I'm helping.
I am assisting.
Don't worry.
A clean pool is.
safe pool what a hero i'm a hero guys okay we'll have it here too about the lemonade stand with the hot dog stand with the shower so right after you know a good wait is that yeah right after a good shower a good shower you get to have a nice lemonade we speed run Lemonade.
Oh, lemonades.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I'll have you know.
This lemon was grown right here in New Zealand.
Why do I stock it up?
Hello?
Oh, I built hot dog.
Oops.
That's a hot dog sack.
Here we go.
Now I build a lemonade stat.
Like, ah, that's a funny color for lemon.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, here.
Now we have a lemonade stat.
And now also, what else did I?
Oh, I built a bigger stat.
There we go.
Oh.
You're waiting for a lemonade.
Don't worry.
I got you.
How do I do this?
ice lemons lemonade I am trying to wow I got your lemon sir take my lemonade take my this is what happens when you don't take my lemonade how dare you that is an insult to sea landman if a sea landman offers you lemonade, and you reject it?
This is the first thing we do.
So don't never reject the Clanders lemonade.
I can't build this, so I have to be here.
I need clearing my trash for it.
Oh.
Kobe.
Oh my god, what a shot.
Woo!
Okay.
Do I have to fix everything?
Oh, I need to actually...
Yeah, the lemonade sign is initiation ritual.
Alright, is there anything else?
Any other trash anywhere?
I don't think so.
Yeah, I think it's fine.
Oh!
Yay!
I gotta test my own pool, you know?
Test your product.
That's what they always say.
Let's see.
I think that's good.
Oh, is one of the showers broken?
No, it's not.
Oh, yeah, never mind.
I got it.
It's broken too?
Oh, they were both broken.
Sorry, you may or may not have got cracks.
If you got a splinter in New Zealand, no, you didn't.
You brought that splinter out of country into our beautiful micro state.
All right, clean, clean, clean.
anything else to clean i'll clean this oh i forgot to look at the reviews they must have been like really good right
right surely yeah they were like five stars or some shit i'm pretty sure
all right uh what else do i need oh i have research points all right where are the workers
staff bigger tips tips visitors stronger hands modern pool lifeguard set where the fuck are my staff members oh vendor staff okay we need that yeah we're gonna go straight to vendor
uh cashier staff all right we need three research points.
No, this is good enough.
We don't need a bigger pool.
They can enjoy this one pool here.
Do you think New Zealand is made out of money?
We are a growing economy.
Yes.
We have yet to reach First Nation status.
First World.
We have yet to reach first world country.
That is why we are asking for financial assistance from our neighbors and allies.
Alright, 6 hours Lad Pass.
Welcome to New Zealand.
Hope you enjoy your stay.
We need financial aid.
Hello, Jay.
Oh, now you want to pay to be here?
That's fucking, right?
Okay.
Hello, Madden.
Welcome back.
Ooh, you've been enjoying your time here?
Your sink is reducing hygiene.
Unlock the water gun and...
Oh, I have that!
Wait, how do I...
That was the first thing I unlocked.
Don't worry.
Be clean!
Four hours.
Oh, wait.
I gotta throw this.
There you go.
Um...
Welcome to New Zealand.
Hope you enjoy your stay.
Oh my god, I have so many customers.
They must have heard all the great things about my wonderful sovereign state.
Yeah, we have to get rid of his aura.
Six hours.
Enjoy your stay.
I mean, to be fair, you can literally just go to take a shower.
There's a shower right there.
May Christ ice compels you that's right don't make me spray the holy water fixed i did it oh my god i'm so close to oh wait he wants lemonade um i want lemonade add ice don't worry i got the ice and i got the lemonade and i got ice again just in case is there pooping no there isn't that's just a that's just a button that's just that Doug.
Oh, I got you.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Just sand out of the pipe.
Oh, shit!
It's not my fault.
You saw him.
He walked into me.
Yes.
I had the right of way.
He walked into my area.
I'm never a fault.
I am the law.
Alright, Leonard Six hours, senior.
Enjoy the complimentary water.
I'm going to pay your taxes in New Zealand.
Enjoy yourself.
Oh, I don't even have to advertise my park anymore.
Six hours, adult slide pass.
Enjoy your stay.
I need to shoot some hoops.
Oh, wait.
Lemonade.
I want lemonade.
Add ice.
Enjoy your lemonade.
It's not pee.
Dirt.
Attraction slowly lose and get dirt.
Use the mop to clean them in the hat.
A shiny water park is a happy water park.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Not in New Zealand.
Can't go back.
We can't get shut down again.
Clear.
Oh, repair damage building.
What's damage?
Hold up, whoa.
Does this count as repairing it?
Oh, it does.
This is how you repair stuff.
Just hammer it until things get better.
Okay, don't worry.
She won't get any splinters from this chair.
Jesus, it takes so long to repair, though.
No, it's not.
They're fine.
It's not my fault they can't aim.
Is it truly my fault if they miss?
They're the ones that can't aim.
It's like when you miss the toilet when you're peeing.
Is it my fault that you have no aim?
No.
I'll clean this chair.
I can clean this while he's there.
But I don't bump.
clean clean clean yeah it's literally a skill diff I open your eyes no you're not I literally did not I'm looking at this area I want lemonade here's your fucking lemonade all right clean clean clean let's clean this it's already clean
Just walk left!
God, we gotta find out where the source of all this water is coming from.
Alright.
Clean, clean, clean.
That's everything.
Oh, hot dogs.
Mustard.
Here you go.
Hope you enjoy our national dish.
Is that everything?
I feel like cleaned everything.
Can I clean?
Oh, wait, I forgot I can clean the showers.
I don't understand why my shower is dirty if it's already water.
Can I clean it while he's showering?
I don't understand.
How is my shower broken when water is being sprayed on it?
Spread the love with water gun?
Don't worry.
I am also a registered priest.
plain have your plain ass hot dog this one's lemonade with no ice ah you want lukewarm lemonade this lemonade's been sitting out for five hours it's clean smelly guests there's no really smelly guests though
at least at least the national dish has poor options I know isn't it wonderful Don't have to worry about picking.
Less choices.
Enjoy your stay in New Zealand.
For our senior slide pass.
Hope you enjoy your stay in New Zealand.
Oh my god.
Who broke my pool?
Oh I could clean my pool.
Oh my god please I can't get out.
Who took away my ladder?
Well I can clean it from here.
Is there anything?
Oh my god, god damn it.
It's stupid fucking water.
I'm gonna drain the pool.
Is that it?
Alright.
Hope you enjoy.
Are you serious?
How did you miss?
The bathroom is literally there.
Okay, maybe having one bathroom in the entire park might not be the best idea.
Might not be the...
Might not be the smartest.
thing I've done today.
Does it take money when I do that?
No, it doesn't.
That's good.
Pew, pew, pew.
Don't worry, I'm baptizing you.
So now to the C-Land religion.
Welcome to C-Landian.
And I sprayed everybody.
Nice.
Okay.
Now they're fine.
Come on, C-Line.
This is the house, C-Line, baptized.
I just need someone to be smelly.
Hello.
Are there anyone with aura here?
Oh, wait.
I think I can hire staff now.
Nice.
Alright, staff.
Open.
Pick your new staff member.
Bring them.
You have to pay them daily, but they keep their part.
Well, sometimes staff takes breaks.
And when they do, their work simply stops.
Keep an eye on that.
Oh, I have to make sure they never stop.
So how do I hire people?
Uh, oh, can I take a loan?
We'll hire someone.
Hire.
Dalton.
Who's the cheapest?
Alright, you.
Efficiency, 87%.
Endurance.
There you go, Lennon.
Congratulations.
You're now a wonderful employee of- Oh, shit!
Oh, I've got you!
I'm a hero.
Alright, I got my first staff.
Where is he?
Oh, Lenin's doing the thing.
Yay!
I don't have to handle tickets anymore.
Nice.
Alright.
I looked at your criteria, Lenin.
And you seem to be the perfect fit for C-Lan.
To be a wonderful diplomatic employee.
And work in government.
I see myself in you, Lenin.
If the only con was that I had to pay you, that's the only criticism because as a wonderful government worker, you should feel honored from just, you should feel honored and required zero pay just for the, just for the fact that you get to work for C-Land matches all the criteria.
The criteria being you were the cheapest of all the C-Land.
staff.
Oh, fuck.
I keep forgetting that you just weren't playing?
Oh.
Why is there not five of Lennon?
So I don't have to worry about handling the hot dog sad.
Wait, actually, I could hire five of Lennon.
I hired this guy.
I did not hire him.
Where is he?
Where's Dalton oh I only can we hire one staff member that's stupid I
should be allowed to have more government workers I
just realized I look like a member from the Beatles I forgot his name everybody's having such a good day at my park everybody but this one oh shit oh give me a sec here you go get out of here get out of here
obi i should put all the trash getting near each other all right i'm injured decorations need improvement okay so the other reviews um that was on their own fault but um the one thing I just need to fix is that I need to make my park a little prettier I can do that I can make my park prettier decorations oh I can't I gotta unlock that I need repair the pool the pool seems okay see only 50% damage do this god cleaning is such a chore I'm trying to play video games to like not clean my room
look they didn't say more bathrooms they just said they want more they just wanted to be prettier um this is supposed to be an escapism why the fuck it i have to clean my own country
all right remember when this used to be blue remember when this slide was was fully blue, guys.
Alright, speed run.
Wait!
Oh my god.
Was I just naked?
Uh...
I want vendor staff, so...
I can't get this.
Oh, I have to unlock that.
And then...
Basic trash bin.
Park size.
Wait, how do I unlock number two?
Oh, is that two star?
Oh, it has to be two star.
Okay.
What star am I at?
Okay, I need to do the smelly guest thing to get two star.
Yeah.
All right, we'll grab this here.
And then we'll put a tree here.
We'll put a chair next to the pool.
Actually, we'll put it here.
So we can stop the falls, guys.
We can stop it.
This is our cushion.
Finally, we won't have any more accidents now.
The chair will stop their fall.
I'm a genius.
Modern solution to a modern problem.
Alright.
Yeah, exactly.
The slide down, it'll be a sick trick shot.
It'll be like an Ollie.
Like, and then they get in the pool.
It'll be a sick trick shot, guys.
It'll be too...
It'll be too bitter.
I think Tony Hawk will be impressed when he sees this.
It's the bridge between this trash can and that trash can.
I don't see any difference between the two.
Tony Hawk's water park.
Alright, Lennon.
Do your job.
I should really get...
Oh, wait.
I can customize.
Oh, my God.
Customize my character.
Guys, I got a new haircut.
You guys like it?
Wait, did I...
Bugged it out?
Why my third person now?
Why am I...
third okay i guess i guess i'm third person now oh that should do clean this i don't know how to fix that it just had oh where did i put where did this part of the the seagulls stop leave where is he oh my god who fed the who pissed the seagulls off No!
Not the sea!
Oh, Mach, this is an aerial strike.
This is an aerial strike.
I got hurled in emergency meeting.
Where's my anti-air artillery?
The great, the great sea land war.
The foreign invaders.
Tragul's return fire Okay, I'll clean this Oh, okay Oh, it's the key What the fuck happened?
Okay, we gotta baptize him Okay, we gotta figure out What to, we gotta clean this up
Can we clean this?
Like, why is it green?
Why is this green?
That's alright.
As long as they don't see this part of the...
Everything will be fine.
As long as they don't see this part of the park.
It should be fine.
Are there any more people?
Okay, there is.
Don't worry, I'll baptize him in the name of Sea Land.
Alright, we need one more and then we'll have five stars.
Oh my god, there's so much work.
Do you think they'll see this?
Guys?
you think you think they are aware of this part of this part of the part it's fine I don't think they see it there's no way lemon oh the last one oh wait no that's just trash I need one more smelly man so I can clean so I can be too stars all right destroy destroy oh god i'm tired why did i expand this park we were happy with the size of the country we were so happy i made a mistake we should have stayed on micro nation This is too much work.
I expanded too fast, guys.
I would...
Why do you need, like, five more for more points?
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait.
Anthony is panicking at the...
Don't worry, Anthony.
I got you.
Don't worry.
Oh, nice.
I got a research point.
Uh...
Yeah, I'm going to save up.
I want to save up for the vendor staff.
See, look at that.
Now he's so brave.
So brave.
Oh, shit.
I didn't want to destroy it.
Trying to see if there's any more trash for me to throw.
Well, here you go.
Enjoy our national cuisine.
He's fine.
He's so healthy.
He signed a consent form, too.
So it's okay.
We're legally safe.
So don't worry, dragons.
Our feudal country exists from any lawsuit.
What are you doing?
Lenin?
Lenin.
What are you doing?
Lenin?
Yes.
Go back.
Lenin.
Why are you leaving?
By becoming a government worker, you're not allowed to leave.
Lennon go back in You are not allowed To leave this country Oh my god You got injured on the bench How what happened?
Who could have done such a thing?
Lennon you're supposed to Chase you're supposed to do a trick shot
No Why is he taking a lunch break Outside the country?
Does he not enjoy our national dish?
That's right, Lennon.
You're here forever.
He fell the cliff.
That's right.
You think you can leave New Zealand now that you know our government secrets?
Lennon is tired.
He's so tired.
All right, here's a lemonade.
Oh, shit.
I gotta fix the chairs.
How How could you ever get tired of hot dogs?
You put ketchup or mustard.
And if you're feeling extra wild, you could put both.
Look at the varieties that we have.
That's so much variety.
Alright.
Six hours.
Teen.
Oh my god.
For hours.
I liked it.
To work.
Minimum wage.
Right.
After Lenin took over.
It was so nice.
I forgot what this was like.
Guess we waited too long.
Leonard is panicking.
Leonard, you're holding the line up.
Get in that pool.
We have paying citizens here.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
How could this happen?
Don't worry.
Trick shot.
Oh, shit.
Who could have pushed you in the pool like that?
all right i got you your lemonade add lemon and ice there you go man everything you've ever wanted
let's get rid of the trash what oh my god where did my trash get back go where did it where did i where did i flung it oh wait i didn't see your papers get out of here
Do I have more?
Oh, I do.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, everyone's so happy.
Look at this.
Everyone is so happy to be here.
I literally just need one more smelly customer so I can add more staff.
Come on.
My water gun's waiting.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh my god, how could this happen?
Guys, we all saw it, right?
He slipped outside of the border.
We all saw it, guys.
And then I, as a hero, he slipped here.
inside our country so I could perform CPR.
We all saw that.
I am a hero.
I was, I willingly let this man into our borders to save his life.
And thus today, We shall, I declare today, to be a appreciate Doki birthday as remembrance for her heroic actions.
September 18th shall now be...
Shall now be Doki Day in remembrance of her being such a hero.
I had to make an important decision.
today to let in a foreigner into our great nation state and save his life and because of my action he decided to become a citizen of New Zealand glory to Doki glory to sea land our first national holiday my generosity truly knows no bounds oh yeah I should start cleaning I know I get a cleaning,
Kerala.
It's cleaning.
We have to come...
Absolutely!
This happened on a work day.
In fact, on Doki Day, you are...
You are honored.
We are giving you the honor to work double over time.
In celebration for my heroic actions, Oh my god Oh my god
I did it
That's what Labor Day should have been
And And on Doki Day By working double overtime Because Wait, guess we're too long for lemon I didn't know you wanted lemonade.
You just shouted for me.
I'm doing a fucking diplomatic speech.
No one with aura has like...
Came to my park yet.
Because you guys love to work for me so much.
You don't get paid on Doki Day.
Because the honor of working on the day.
I've saved lives.
is pay enough I got three reviews today guys whoops oh fuck up wait they explode if I miss nice oh my god that was a cool trick shot please
I just want two stars please let me have two stars I think I think it's clean enough
Wee!
I don't know how people are getting injured at my...
at my park.
I wonder how that's happening.
Oh, new research point.
Nice.
Who knows?
It's actually...
Oh wait, my... Oh shit!
I'm repairing.
And now clean.
Yeah!
Oh my god, it's so dirty.
Like, what are they doing to my benches?
Oh, they're disgusting sweaty bodies doing to my benches.
Honestly, it's a skill diff if you get injured in my part.
It is up to code.
It's up to C-Land code.
Clean, clean, clean.
Clean, clean.
Like, are you fucking, like, pooping on my chairs?
Like, why are they...
It's been one day.
Why is it like this?
Yeah, I think that's clean.
I think everything's clean now.
Society!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Naked, jingo, jingo.
Yeah, the people here are so fucking dirty.
It's like they came to my pool and, like, didn't shower.
Everything is good.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I can sit on the chair.
Where am I?
Oh, okay.
It's because I was like, am I sitting on my chair?
Alright.
Everything's fixed.
I literally need one guy with aura so I can get two stars.
Look, if you guys want handouts, go to a gym.
This is a luxury.
Go to a gym if you want handouts.
All right, I'll fix my one bathroom.
I'll fix this too.
Yay.
Hammer, hammer.
Oh my god.
There must be an upgrade where I can upgrade.
faster.
Or I could hammer faster.
It's like so fucking long.
We're on my cleaning crew.
Lenin, please work a little faster, Lenin.
Lenin, I see a lie.
I do not pay you $100 a day.
Wait, he gets paid $100 a day?
Oh my god!
You're a...
How is that?
Oh shit.
Lenin, why are you trying to take a hundred dollars from me?
And it's a hundred dollars euros too, because that is the national currency of Sealand.
I'll teach him a lesson.
If he's gonna take a hundred dollars from me every day, He's gonna take $200 a day from me.
I'm gonna make sure he spends that when you're even at the hospital.
Wait, where's the shower?
It's broken?
Which one?
This one?
What thing's broken?
He lied!
They're lying!
Oh, shit.
You still want your lemonade?
Ma'am?
Ma'am, do you still want your lemonade?
Oh, nice.
That's good.
She still wants it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait, not that.
I got you, sir.
Oh, shit.
I got you.
Clear.
I saved them.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, please do not jump in an empty pool.
This is a Darwin.
This is a Darwin test right now.
All right, nice.
Oh my god.
Thank god, finally.
Yay!
Start earning top of your guess, the better.
Am I two star?
Unlocked to swim, still not two star?
Slurring guess, get free.
Nothing hits the spot.
Set up a lemonade side.
Where's my two star?
Oh, shit.
Uh.
Okay, somebody spilled lemonade in front of my lemonade stand.
I thought I was too star.
Oh, fuck.
Don't worry.
She's still alive.
She's still breathing.
She's still breathing, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm slowly heading over.
Clear.
Oh, God.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Just a normal day.
Let's see, lad.
All right, oh nice, we have lemonators.
You know what?
Just lemonade, plain old lemonade?
I got you.
Okay, I don't got you, but please give me a sec.
We just got it.
We're, this is all, we're this all like grown in our nation, so give us a sec.
I got you.
Homegrown in our beautiful country.
There you go.
Yay.
please I just want two stars that's all I want please I want more people to buy my big great lemonade it's organic too it's very organic
nicely squeezed not bottled our
soil is very nutritious very organic we make sure the lemons are fed with the best grains possible.
It's grass.
It's grass fed, guys.
Come on, you know, you want to get some lemon in.
Thank God.
It's grass fed.
Come on.
Lemon in.
Any lemon in, enjoyers?
Lemonade enjoyers!
Hello, hello!
Come on, would you like some wonderfully organic lemonade that was grown right here in the great micro-nation of New Zealand?
Come on!
You know you want to...
Oh, I wish there was physics.
I would push you into my lemonade stand.
Hello, everyone!
Lemonade!
Get your lemonade!
Each purchase of lemonade saves a starving child in Africa.
Lemonade.
If you don't buy my lemonade, you want that starving child to die.
You want that?
Lemonade.
Oh my god.
These guys are fucked up.
I can't believe it.
They don't want to save a starving child.
Yes, and...
I can't believe it.
It's so cruel.
They're all people here just want to waste my water.
They're so selfish.
So fucking selfish.
Think of the children.
It's like when they don't want to donate 99 cents.
Why are you bored?
I have all the basic necessities.
That's right.
Regret everything.
Hey, mustard.
Watch your mustard.
He needs a nap.
Watch your cleanness.
Yeah.
Have fun now.
Why
does everyone want hot dogs?
Does no one want lemonade so more?
Lemmaids are so good.
Someone please.
Buy lemonade.
Please enjoy.
Buy my lemonade now and enjoy yourself.
I don't understand.
I just want to be two stars.
the one time i wanted to actually fucking buy lemonade they don't buy lemonade i should put an umbrella here just because i can
why is he what is she thinking of hey what is that even you're right maybe i get more customers or get more get more people to immigrate to my country hello come to my country Hello, anyone want to revoke their citizenship and immigrate to New Zealand?
We have a lot of taxes, but that's the best part.
Oh, you're so right.
We need, like, five lemonade scents.
So they'll buy...
You're so right, guys.
If I have...
If I have five lemonade scents, they'll make them want to buy more lemonade.
You're so right.
There you go.
subliminal messaging you know it's so subtle the more lemonade stands there are the more the one to buy it it's the most subtle marketing tactic you can do
I like but hello I need to put some more lemons in my lemonade stand surely this will work
Oh, it's because of all the...
I was going to say, how did I lose money?
I think I bought...
Guys, I may or may not have bought too many lemonade stands.
Maybe.
I'm not sure yet.
Guys, I'm not sure yet.
I may or may not have bought too many lemonade stands.
I don't know.
I'm unsure.
Alright, let's see.
No, Lenin is... This is all he has.
He can't leave the country anymore, so he's here forever.
I should repair my toilet.
It's okay.
Sometimes people leave, like, money on the floor.
Alright.
I repaired everything.
I mean, the chairs are not...
That badly broken.
Just need to mop them a little bit.
It's okay.
We're open now.
Come on.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Keep slipping.
Like, this has to be, like, the most slamiest floor ever.
There's no way that's water.
I refuse to believe that's water.
I gotta go to, like, Wee!
See, I don't understand how people can get injured from that.
It feels so safe.
Is this clean?
I think that's clean.
Oh, yeah, I should stir that away.
Oh, shit.
No, I don't even... I thought I hid it.
All right.
Oh, nice.
The customers are coming in.
Is that this you?
Get out of here.
We don't welcome you to New Zealand.
Does anyone want lemon in?
Oh, wait.
We need another.
Okay, nice.
I can finally afford more lemon in.
All right.
Now, surely...
Surely I have enough customers to buy lemonade now.
Hey guys.
Look at, yay, five thought.
Look, she had a good time.
She did a good, she did a trick shot.
And she enjoyed herself.
It's a lemon eat lemon world.
I wonder if the slide was supposed to be closer to the water.
I don't know.
I guess we'll never know.
Guys, we'll never know.
Why would...
Yeah, it's like...
experience you'll never forget guys maybe I need more lemonade stands maybe I need more why are they purchasing my lemonade do I do you think I maybe I just need more lemonade stands that's gotta be it
no you don't but why aren't they buying my lemonade then this is now this is now a lemonade park pools are optional what the fuck is going wrong guys i think she just had a seizure on my in my park i'm just waiting i'm just waiting for lemonade how much is a lemonade stand 300 okay maybe i just need another lemonade stand guys maybe that's it if i had Four lemonade stands.
That's where the money starts rolling.
It's the color read.
When was the last time you swapped?
We don't talk about that.
What are you, a cop?
Why are you asking?
Lemonade?
Hello.
Lemonade.
Who the fuck is?
Oh, that's my staff.
What?
I was like, who the fuck?
Fuck is Lenin.
I just know lemonade.
How is no one buying lemonade?
I forgot my...
Guys, my head is just lemonade.
There's only lemonade here.
Oh my god, lemonade!
Oh my gosh, she actually wants lemonade.
Hello, what do you want?
Oh my god, thank god.
My god, you also I knew it guys.
I told you I told you It just works it just works I knew investing in three lemonade stands would start making me money Oh shit.
Oh shit If you read the terms and condition is not my fault that you failed a trick shot Skilled it skilled death
I legal disclaimer you oh my god where did i go you missing this the trick shot is purely skill defense and the park is not legally obligated to do anything about it
oh we gotta clean this we can't have this disrupting our lemonade path
they signed they said yes to the terms and condition on sea land plus so they can't do anything about it if they get injured on my park Oh, fuck.
Okay, it didn't explode.
That's all that matters.
Wee!
Wait, Ruby's waiting for a lemonade?
Where's Ruby?
Yeah.
Lemonade.
Here you go.
Here's your lemonade.
Why are so many people getting injured in my park?
I don't understand.
So many weak-ass citizens.
We need to train them.
How am I receiving a fine?
Oh my god, I can afford more lemonade stands.
Thank god.
Yeah.
There we go.
This is what our part needed.
Alright.
And now...
Now we just restock.
How can this business plan fail?
There's no way this can fail.
This is a beautiful business plan.
There you go.
Here's your lemonade.
It's too big.
We're too big to fail.
Oh shit, she wants hot.
Okay, I know you want hot stuff, but...
lemonade she should have picked lemonade why upgrade when you just buy more lemonade guys i need five more lemonade customers oh nice we have three new customers
when life gives you lemons you make more lemonade is that what it's called
okay sweet sweet sweet And they don't want you to know this one simple trick.
This get rich quick scheme.
Just order more lemonade.
See?
He hit the pool.
He was able to do it.
I clean this.
I have maximum amount of guests, though.
I don't need to advertise.
Alright.
Nice.
Wait, I could wait.
Can I let...
Have, like, more people?
Oh, guess we'll pay more?
Yeah, I'll grab that.
I like more money.
I don't have to change anything, and they'll just willingly pay me more money.
Sign me up.
Oh.
Wait, where's Lenin?
Lenin, where did you go?
I didn't know Lenin got tired!
I didn't know Lenin!
Lennon, why did you get Eevee?
No name.
Thank you for the silver chat.
Thank you.
Four out of five stars.
The slide was too far from the pool.
I ended up scraping my back and banging my head on the concrete while the owner watched.
The lemonade was okay though.
So for... See, look at that!
Look, I'm sorry, but like, that's a skill issue.
Look, she hit the pool just fine.
I'm sorry, but that's just a skill issue.
I'm glad you like the lemonade.
I'm literally just waiting for lemonade.
That's all I need.
I need lemonade.
Things stay clean.
Oh, I should get that.
That seems like pretty convenient.
it's fine there we go get in the pool I demand you to have fun now take another break let in
the lemon the lemon is oh my god look she took she had a fun nap she took a nap on see the slide to the bench what a fun time penguin they give us super chat thank you thank you there will probably be less injuries if the slides actually landed people in the water thank you the super chat thank you thank you but what are you a fucking doctor or something where's your license huh do you own a water park i don't think so
yeah where's the source huh marshall thank you with the super chat thank Thank you.
I thought the pool would be filled with lemonade.
No, we have...
Look, we have money.
Look, a whole $2.
That's...
Look at that, guys.
A whole $2.
We didn't go under.
We didn't go negative.
So that's already a good day.
All right, let's clean this.
Oh, the shower's broken.
Got to fix that.
And then sweep, sweep, sweep.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Sweep, sweep.
Poor's so healthy.
Oh, wait.
The poor is so healthy now.
Okay, it should stay cleaner longer now, too.
But already?
Why did you go to the fucking water park if you're scared stupid there you go now you have another fear i fixed you so being scared of the pool be scared of real what the fuck did i get a heart attack
here now you can be scared of actual real things
yeah i'm giving him a new fear in life
I fix your fears by replacing your phobias with new fears.
It's okay, just a little heart attack.
That's just business.
You know you're a hard worker when you get one or two heart attacks.
That's when you know you're doing something right.
It builds character.
Okay, that's not a new one.
You literally walked in front of my hammer.
I did not move one time.
Does anyone buy more lemonade?
You know what?
I know what to do.
Wait, I should...
Oh, I can have more slides?
Oh, wait.
Wait, is that...
Is that a free look?
Get out of here!
That's...
Oh, yoying, $40.
Wait, I want people to illegally enter my country.
So I can rob them.
I get more money from them illegally entering than they do paying $40 whole dollars Oh lemonade Lemonade Lemonade Lemons Here you go Enjoy your lemonade
I need I need like $100 and I can buy another lemonade stand
Alright it's fine God, I have so many weak citizens.
We gotta take him to training.
To boot camp.
Maybe I'll stop fucking falling.
Wait, you're right.
What if, like, what if my slides lead to the lemonade?
Wait, can I do that?
Oh my god, two customers?
Two whole customers?
I know.
Enjoy your Lemonade.
Lemon and ice.
Oh my god.
My lemonade business is going up.
Wait, can I actually have the slides lead to the lemonade stand?
Wait, that's brilliant.
Does it happen?
Oh my god, that's brilliant.
That's actually so smart.
Wait.
Okay, we gotta destroy this.
do i get my money back yes i do okay all right put this here
okay wait actually
oh my god dude wait all right i gotta figure this out this has to be like coordinated perfectly all right we have our cool ass lot right here then
oh my god it's beautiful oh shit that they have to take my lemonade I'm a genius in the making
oh my god please there you go I just gotta grab lemons I just gotta grab lemons
slide anymore it's a lemon slide oh my god it's working
oh i built a hot dog stand instructions unclear i accidentally built a hot dog stand i
instructions unclear i built the wrong type of stand okay No, please take my lemonade!
No, I didn't even...
Okay, I'll break this.
No hot dogs, sir.
No hot dogs.
I built the wrong one.
There we go.
Now!
Now it's perfect.
Sir, give me a sec.
I'll fix...
Give me a sec.
Yeah.
Okay.
Clear!
Alright, nice.
I'm a hero.
I'll fix this bathroom.
But there will never be a lemon shortage in New Zealand.
We grow our...
We grow every lemon.
To avoid that.
What the fuck keeps...
I have a...
Oh, it's because...
Whoops, sorry.
I forgot that.
Alright.
perfect this is a perfect plan
oh here lemon hello ma'am would you like some lemons ma'am it's okay I got I got I got the juice hello ma'am would you like some lemons
see my plan is foolproof it's genius oh my god there's so many lemons customers
no it's okay i still have this one
yay i have to do more still not two star oh my god i gotta repair
okay i need bigger trash bags i think i have that already
bigger trash bags where is that
oh there it is okay I did not have that build zero lounge of at least one prestige oh my god but I can't afford it I spent it all on I spent it all on lemons a repair rusty lounge oh here where can I get a money for that I went all in on the lemons
Yeah All right, we're gonna have to restock our hot dog Wait, it's speed tech
How could you say that?
How could you say destroy the hot dogs?
Or the lemons?
This is our main source of economy
that.
I need the loungers that are one point that are what?
Build zero to five for at least one prestige.
What is one prestige?
What is considered one prestige?
Like one star?
I mean, there's one star on this chair.
Is that not count?
Oh, that doesn't count?
But that's one star.
This should count, right?
Oh, it doesn't.
I guess I'll destroy it.
God, I'll destroy it.
It doesn't count.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
I got you, man!
You're fine!
Would you like some lemonade too.
Wait, what do I have to unlock?
Park.
Oh, basic loungers.
This one?
Oh, I see.
Okay, I need five.
One, two, three, four, five.
There you go.
That should give me two stars, right?
Oh my god, moving up in the world.
one two three four am I two star yay I got my second start guys see ignore what they say about my pie about how it's dangerous and and a crime against humanity.
They still gave me...
Oh, wait.
Almost...
Oh.
Good.
If you round up, it's what?
Two stars.
I take those.
I round it up.
I rounded it up.
And so I never doubted it.
It still counts.
It did not kill anyone.
Maybe they can't walk again.
But there was no deaths.
There was...
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The super medic simulator chair looks fun.
Someone should probably arrest the owner of the water park, though.
Thank God this isn't a water park.
It's just a sovereign...
Oh my God!
Oh my god, oh my god, wait, wait
Everything is fine
Nothing happened Everything is fine She was just drunk and called her friend to pick her up Guys, she was drinking at the...
Don't drink and drink Swim.
Don't drink and swim, guys.
Don't...
No one died.
Hey, guys.
I'm fun.
I'm going to call it here.
But I hope you guys had a lot of fun today.
Watching me expand the great sovereign micro state.
Sea land.
And enjoyed watching me run New Zealand.
Glory to New Zealand.
Glory to the Duchess of Jokie Bane.
Thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Foster check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you step for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!